So we've covered a lot of ground today.
We've set up materials inside of Unreal.
We've gone through the PBR pipeline and explained how to import content into the editor and
talked about adding existing content from different sources.
And then we've really deep dived into the material editor showing you just a Vector3
color material setup all the way into creating just this big pair of material that can house
Albedo maps and specular maps, normal maps, etc.
As well as then having control over the UV functionality and even creating basic conditional
statements using the switcher.
And then we showed you a quick emissive tip as well.
So a lot of ground covered.
Hopefully it was all useful and interesting and we'll see you on the next course.